Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the Round
Table of Dim Lighting,
we are going down the rabbit hole.
Watch out now.
Using new methods.
Who knows what we're
gonna talk about today.
Who knows who's gonna drop in?
Sure, we might have somebody special,
real special drop in.
I got somebody special
who said they were gonna drop in.
They had something they wanted to say,
and because they're kin,
Oh.
you know, I can't,
I can't deny his request.
Might be, oh his.
Might be your son, one of your sons.
Nope.
Hmm.
You have a rogue hair.
How's that?
I mean, here's the thing.
I think it was fine when it was down,
but I know that you would
want me to tell you.
Thank you.
So.
If it falls down again.
Is it up?
You know, it's up, but I'm gonna give you,
I'll tell you two more times, max.
Okay.
Happens a fourth time,
Just gimme a signal.
Let's not make this part of the podcast.
Let's just make it a signal.
You know, this is good.
This is for the people
who are just listening,
and like, I gotta watch
that YouTube version.
I gotta see that rogue hair.
I like his beard.
I like when they throw
little things in there like that, Link.
I thought you did it on
purpose for that reason.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, so we're gonna go
down the rabbit hole,
but before we go down the rabbit hole,
we're gonna go into the bear cave.
That's my way of saying
that I'm gonna tell a story
about a bear.
Oh spoiler.
So recently, and here's the thing.
I already told you this story,
and can you just act like I haven't?
I was going to.
Typically, I wait to say things,
but we were in this
mixed company situation,
and I really needed to tell you the story.
I needed to tell somebody else the story,
and I was like, I just don't
wanna do the Ear Biscuits thing
where I hold it for a few weeks.
Yeah, and when you say mixed company,
what do you mean by that?
You know, people who you do a podcast with
and people you don't.
Is that what you mean
by mixed company?
What does mixed company
usually mean?
Mixed company, I thought was like,
Men and women?
when it's like co-ed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean it was in that sense.
It was.
It was a co-ed group.
Yeah, there was all
types of genders there,
and everyone was, well I don't know
if everyone was represented.
No.
Everyone wasn't represented.
Right.
No, yeah.
How's that even possible?
Yeah, that's true.
I don't, yeah, I mean,
You know?
I don't even know why
I said mixed company.
I don't know why I made
it about representation.
People who are my friends and you.
It's a good story.
I'm gonna hear it like
it's the first time.
Good.
Okay, so I, Jessie and I
took a little weekend away
with our friends, Lance
and Lacey, you know,
our long-time friends
who are responsible for
You know, mixed company.
the Beard and Lady products
that we sell, our grooming line.
That's right.
Been friends for a very long time,
probably 15 years now.
And they were coming into town,
and we were like, hey,
they're coming into town
without their children.
So we were like,
Jackpot.
hey, why don't we
For them.
leave our child,
Jackpot for you.
and just go to the mountains?
Let's get away from this heat.
It was that crazy hot heatwave weekend
that we had recently.
Yeah.
So we just went to a place
that was probably 20 degrees cooler,
which was nice.
In the woods.
Yeah, and it's not uncommon
when you visit these places
in the California mountains
that there's lots of, you know,
if you're doing an Airbnb,
there's all kinds of information
that you're overwhelmed with
when you arrive at the Airbnb.
And in this particular case,
some of that information mentioned bears,
but like, more mentions
than seemed necessary.
Like it was in the email,
it was in the handbook,
it was a sign on the door.
On the door?
Just all kinds of stuff,
like do not leave any food outside,
or else you will be fined $4,500.
Good gosh.
Because there are bears
in this here neighborhood,
and they are hungry bears.
And I'm like, okay, well yeah.
Yeah, I mean, theoretically,
Right?
Theoretically.
So we, this is the first
night we, you know,
we hang out, we eat some food,
we leave food out.
Outside?
No, on the kitchen counter.
Like we had brought food,
like some fruit, some chips,
stuff that doesn't go inside the refridge.
Okay.
And stuff that's not
gonna go in a cabinet.
It's just like, kind
of out on the counter.
Yeah, but they said don't
leave the food outside.
They said don't leave it outside.
So we didn't do that.
Now the way this place
was set up is that it had,
what I believe is like a south-facing,
almost a complete glass wall,
like four sets of sliding doors,
and then a bunch of glass on top.
So like, it's southern facing,
like, just window, you know,
get the view of the valley, situation.
That's a great way to face.
And let's lot of sun in.
Yeah, but you're not blinded by the sun
on a set or a rise.
It's more of you get.
Correct.
You get it throughout the day.
So when it's cold, it really warms it up.
That was really an irrelevant point.
Well let's not start pointing those out.
But.
In your story.
So we go to sleep, and we're sleeping
in two separate rooms, you
know, at least couples are.
Okay.
Each couple's in a separate room.
Mixed company.
It was that kind, it
was that kind of thing,
where you each get your own bedroom.
And Lance and Lacey said to us,
you know, we tend to
get up a little early.
Also time change, you know,
they're on the Central East Coast.
Central?
Central.
Central time zone?
Central time zone.
And so, you know, we'll be quiet,
but we might get up a little
bit earlier than y'all.
Like, ten four.
Probably didn't actually say ten four,
I probably just said okay.
But then, it's like seven
o'clock in the morning,
and this is vacation time.
So seven o'clock's very early.
And we begin to hear, wow,
somebody's really making
a racket upstairs.
And if I may, you know,
if you hadn't mentioned bears at all,
I would just point out, you know,
I'm not trying to tell
you storytelling 101 here,
but like if it were me,
I probably wouldn't have
mentioned bears at all.
No, because.
My preamble wouldn't
have been about bears.
The tension.
But here's the thing, I got people hooked.
They haven't fast-forwarded
through this part.
Oh, you were afraid.
It's all about
Okay, that's legitimate.
You have to make a choice.
That's legitimate.
Yeah.
I mean, did you see how big
Brian and Logan's eyes got
when I said somebody's rummaging?
That happened out there
on the airwaves too.
I mean, you gotta choose your battles.
Right.
Now, everybody's thinking
that you're about to get
in a bear point of the story.
So in my, I would advise you to,
give 'em a left turn.
You're crimping my style
at this point.
Yeah. Yeah.
And we're like, wow, okay.
They said they, they said
they might be up early,
but this seems disrespectful.
The level of loudness seems disrespectful,
you know?
Right.
What are they doing up there?
It was probably them though.
And now cut to Lance and
Lacey in their own bedroom,
saying to one another,
Rhett and Jessie, we didn't
think they were gonna get up.
We didn't think that they
were gonna get up this early
and be making this kinda racket.
At which point, Lance gets up
and goes into the main area
of the house, which is like
a living room, a dining room,
and a kitchen all open together.
And at that point,
Oh, open floor plan.
Nice.
He sees a bear.
No way.
No, hold on, what?
Mm-hmm.
In the kitchen?
No, it was outside.
Okay.
See, but I got you.
It was a bear standing on the deck,
standing up with its hands on the screen,
ripping through the screen to get,
right next to the handle,
to get to the handle,
to open the handle of the
sliding glass door to come inside
and get the food that it smelled,
and I guess saw on the counter.
The bananas and chips?
And I said, how big was said,
first of all, he sees the
bear, he says to Lacey,
it's a bear.
And he goes back to get his phone,
and when he comes back, the bear has gone.
So the bear did not get inside,
but the bear was actively
trying to open the door.
Bears are smart.
They know how these things work.
So it took, it basically ripped.
In fact, I just texted 'cause
I didn't get a picture.
I texted Lacey and Lance to
see if they got a picture
of the screen.
They just, he just shredded the screen?
If we have that,
you're seeing that in
the YouTube version now.
But honestly, I don't know
if we have it, because.
But what is it?
I mean was it like,
was the whole screen ripped off?
No, it was two spots on the
screen were four strips,
like a bear claw.
Oh wow.
And then a spot that
it just ripped through
right next to the handle
to get to the handle
of the glass door.
It was shimmying the handle?
And thankfully we, yeah,
that what was making,
it was grabbing onto the handle
and trying to get it open.
And thankfully, we locked
all the sliding glass doors,
and we put the reinforcement
like, you know,
the little like wood rods to
keep the doors from opening?
And we were like, well dad gum,
that bear was really coming in.
I mean, these people weren't lying.
I mean if you would've
left the door unlocked,
and the rod out.
The bear would've come in.
Yeah, he would've walked into a bear
just like eating the nanner.
Well, the story is not over my friend,
because we get up, we have
a laugh about the bear.
We begin to realize that
the bear may come back.
But my theory was that the
bear was making its rounds,
and it makes its rounds and
tries things and opens things
to see if, and if people are there,
I mean, it's not like people
have been killed by bears
in this place that we're at.
I don't think so.
I don't think there's a
history of a bear attack
or something like that.
That wasn't in the
booklet, or on the door,
or in the email?
But you don't wanna be the first,
and you don't wanna find out.
But about an hour later, we
decided we would walk outside,
at which point, the first thing I see
when I look outside is our car,
and the driver's side
door to the car is open.
That's a good feeling.
At that point,
I remembered another thing that I read,
which was lock your car doors.
If he's going for a
sliding glass door knob.
So I'm like, it's probably,
I know we didn't leave that door open,
but I'm pretty sure we didn't lock it.
'Cause I drove and I've
gotten completely spoiled
because the car that I
drive is tied to your phone.
So once you get about 20
feet away from my car,
it automatically locks.
Oh, behave.
And so basically, what ends up happening
is that when I drive Jessie's
car, I forget to lock it,
because I'm like, oh, isn't
it supposed to do this
when I get 20 feet away anyway?
Mm-hmm.
Spoiled.
So.
So this has got your
fault written all over it.
I'm approaching the SUV,
and the door is open.
You creeping, right?
And we got tinted windows,
and we tined 'em too much,
probably beyond the legal limit,
so I can't see into the back.
Damn, you're living on the edge.
And I'm like,
what are the chance,
the bear was just here,
what are the chances that
I'm gonna go up to this car,
and the bear's gonna be in there?
I mean.
At least 50%.
Maybe. Yeah.
'Cause I believe it was
in there at one point.
I creeped to the car.
I stop, I wait.
I'm assuming that there's
gonna be some sort of movement
that the bear.
Did you like throw a stick at the car?
No, I just thought, if
there's a bear in there,
it'll be rummaging.
And I didn't see any motion.
So I go up, and I just opened
the door a little bit more,
'cause it was like half closed.
Look in, no bear.
But the first thing that I'm thinking
is I've seen these
pictures about what bears,
of what bears will do to your car.
They'll pry open a door like
taking the lid off of a can.
And not just that.
When they get into your car,
typically what will happen,
in fact, there was a picture
at the general store in town,
and it said bears versus car,
and it said lock your car doors.
And it had these pictures
of the interiors of cars
that had been bearified.
And they just go in there, and
they smell, like, a goldfish
that your kid dropped
into the seat cushion,
and they rip the seat
cushion up to get to it.
Thankfully,
Buried treasure.
I guess my kids are old now,
and we only got one at home now.
The only thing that I could
find is there was dirt
on the driver's seat,
'cause it had gotten up
with its dirty paws, and then it had gone
into the back seat, and
there was one claw mark
where it kind of like went in kind of deep
on the leather seats.
Punctured it.
Didn't completely go through.
And I am, I think I am showing
a picture of that right now,
unless it's like bounced back.
But that was the only
evidence that I could find
that it was in there.
And it definitely was in
there, and then it left.
In the back seat too?
Yeah, it like, I think it went over,
and like looked in the back seat,
and probably smelled,
and then decided it was nothing.
I cannot believe that your
car was not ripped to shreds.
Oh, we're so lucky.
I mean, had you cleaned out your car?
I mean like, I'm not
trying to dog on you here,
but like I've been in, this
is Jessie's car, right?
Oh yeah.
I've been in Jessie's car.
I mean Jessie's car has, it's just,
it's an accumulation
zone for like, I mean.
Mostly not food though.
It's like design samples, and like tile,
and a bunch of carpet
samples and curtains.
Yeah. Okay.
It's like a design woman's car, you know.
Designing Women, remember that show?
That's what, it's like
what you imagine the inside
of their car to be.
But no smoothie remnants?
No like granola.
Listen, you're as just as,
I'm just as surprised as you.
You were spared dude.
That was cr, I mean especially,
there's signs everywhere.
It's like every time,
every point in the story,
I thought you'd done
telling me about signs,
there's more warnings.
It's like, this is definitely on you.
Well, and we kept thinking
that the bear was gonna.
General store.
We kept thinking the bear was
gonna come back, you know.
They can open doors.
Oh, and there was zero
evidence of a bear claw.
I mean, I don't know
how to open some doors.
Well.
Like your Tesla would've
been impervious to a bear.
'Cause I don't know how
to get in that thing.
We, no, I would say a
Tesla is like bear-proof.
And I don't know how to
get out of it either.
And maybe that's the whole point.
Like I pulled the thing
that a normal person
would get out of the car.
You're not supposed to pull anything.
And then you're like, oh,
you're supposed to push,
don't pull the thing that
normally would get you
outta the car.
Push the button.
It looks like it's supposed
to roll the window down.
I didn't design the car.
That's what opens the door.
I'm not defending Tesla.
But it also rolls the
window down a little bit.
So it rolls the window down and
opens the door a little bit.
Yeah.
I'm like, what?
So bring the bear in.
I need to know how to
get out of this thing.
But it's, all they have to
do is stick their hands up
under the handle, and just pull,
and they have figured it out.
Their bear hands.
Like they have completely
figured this out.
That's why inside the house,
the trash cans had, just the
trash cans inside the house,
under the, like under
the sink were bear-proof,
had bear-proof lids on them,
so that if it happens to
get in, it can't, like,
'cause they, they just
know how to open stuff.
Smelling stuff.
You have to create some weird way
that they can't get into things.
So anyway, I survived.
Thanks for, thanks for being concerned.
But yeah, those bear warnings.
I'd already heard the story.
Those bear warnings are,
I don't think I've ever,
I don't know if I've actually
had a bear encounter.
I have in my own backyard.
You have.
I mean it's like the bears
turn over the trash cans and.
But did you have to pay a fine?
I mean if it's $4,500,
did you report this to the people?
Oh yeah, well them getting into my car.
No, I mean the door, like the ripped door.
Yeah but we didn't do anything wrong.
We didn't violate any rules.
Leaving food on the
counter is not a problem.
But, so you had a conversation with 'em?
I actually, right before we
started recording, it hit me.
I said, I texted Jessie 'cause
it was her Airbnb account,
and I said, did you ever tell the owner
that the reason the
screen door was ripped up
and ripped off was because of a bear?
And she was like, yes, I told him.
Okay.
So they knew.
Also, just weird side
note, but kind of cool.
First Airbnb I've ever stayed
at where they had merch.
There was a closet full
of hoodies and t-shirts.
I stayed here and survived a bear attack.
And it said, did you forget?
Did you, you know, did
you forget a sweatshirt
or something like that?
Just take one home, and let us know,
and we'll add it to your bill.
And it was like a brand.
It's like a company that owns the house
or something, I guess.
Okay.
But anyway, it was pretty cool.
Jessie got one.
Jessie and Lacey did.
I guess, because they're pretty
nice hoodies, and they were,
I mean they're selling 'em for 40 bucks.
That's a pretty good price for a hoodie.
That's not bad for a hoodie.
Yeah.
I mean if you go, if you go to a show,
I went to the Kendrick Lamar concert.
You buy, I mean hundred
dollars for a hoodie.
Yeah. Easy.
I mean, it had two naked people on it.
$50 each.
Yeah.
And they were, I think it was either a ti,
they were on a tiger rug.
Yeah? Did you get one?
For my son, yeah.
To wear to high school.
You got him naked people on his clothes.
No, I didn't.
I just made a lot of jokes about it.
Well son, I know which
one I'm getting you.
And then I was like none,
'cause it's a hundred dollar hoodie.
It's like.
You get him a t-shirt?
Nope, the line was too long.
Honestly, I was like, you know what,
I don't like anything
that he's got up here.
So I don't wanna wait in line.
You don't like, Kendrick
doesn't have good merch?
He didn't have great merch, in my opinion.
That's a surprise.
Yeah.
I mean, maybe it's too,
too ahead of his time.
Probably.
You know, it'll be cool
three years from now.
I mean, don't get me wrong,
all of his merch is classic.
It's just, it's just, I don't
find myself going back to it.
That's what I would say
about his new album.
The show was awesome though.
Oh, oh wow.
Yeah. A hundred.
Shots fired.
I was like Lincoln, honestly,
if I really liked something,
I would get in line and I would get it.
And then I'd probably
get you something too.
But at this point, if you
really want something,
you need to buy it with your own money,
and stand in line by yourself.
And I don't think any of this is worthy.
He's like, yeah.
So I basically talked him
out of him trying to talk me
into buying him something.
Hmm. Hmm.
Sometimes you just need a
t-shirt for the memory though.
I like to get a t-shirt at a show,
but I just couldn't find anything
that actively appealed to me.
It was a shame.
Surprising.
But you enjoyed the show?
I loved the show. Yes.
Did anybody open up for him?
Wouldn't trade it for the world.
Baby Keem, his cousin.
They produce, they, you know,
he came back out, and they
did a couple of songs.
Last night of the US tour.
How old is the Baby Keem?
How old is Baby Keem?
He's, he, he walks.
He can walk, he can, he can talk.
He can rap in complete sentences.
So he's at least five.
Okay. All right.
But he appears to be much older than that.
How old does he appear to be?
He appears to be in his
mid twenties, maybe 30.
Wow.
It's hard to tell.
Okay. That's an old baby.
Definitely not much of a baby.
Hmm.
I don't know.
I bet you he's in his twenties.
How old is Baby Keem?
21? He's 21?
Oh, okay.
He's still baby.
He is still a baby.
I said he could be 30.
You know, it's like, it's
dramatically lit on stage.
You know?
I was within nine years.
That ain't bad.
But you didn't see a bear.
Of course, I didn't really either.
No, but boy, you had me
on the edge of my seat.
I was wondering when a
bear was gonna show up.
Hey, we're going to MythiCon.
You might not be able to make it.
We understand.
But we want you to share in the experience
of the first ever MythiCon, so
we are making our stage show,
which is a cornerstone of
the MythiCon experience,
a live streaming ticketed
event that you can enjoy
from the comfort of
wherever you comforted.
Yeah, so this is the Saturday
night, October 29th show.
This is gonna be a weird show.
I'm just gonna be honest with you.
We're doing something that, yeah,
we're doing a number
of things on this stage
that we've never done before,
and we will probably never do again.
And so we were like.
Not because it didn't work,
but because.
It's just a one, it's a special thing.
It's just gonna, yeah,
it's just gonna be once you do it once,
I don't think
you do it again.
I mean,
we're gonna try something.
We're gonna try something that
may have incredible results.
We're taking some big risks.
Big risk.
And creatively and
Logistically?
existentially.
I would say that.
We are taking some big risks,
and we're taking you into account.
Yeah, so.
So get a ticket.
In order to make sure
that every mythical beast
has an opportunity to be a part
of what we're doing that night,
we're partnering with Kiswe
to host a live-ticketed,
live stream event.
Okay?
You said live twice.
Yeah, well I wanna make
sure you know it's live.
Pre-sale tickets available now
for all Mythical Society members.
And then we're gonna have the general sale
starting on Wednesday, okay?
Join the Mythical Society.
Get your tickets today.
Mythicontickets.com.
Okay.
A live stream.
Link, you know, last time,
Check it before you wreck it.
I experimented with a couple
of conversation-starting websites,
and I have since upped my
game, did a little research.
Okay.
And I've upgraded.
To what?
Randomquestionmaker.com.
Still not a sponsor.
Okay.
Random question maker dot com.
But this lets you set the
tone of the questions.
What do you mean?
You can select from
candid, weird, icebreaker,
creative and funny.
So of course, I went with weird.
Great.
Okay, so I'm gonna,
I'm gonna ask you a weird question.
I'm gonna ask us a weird question.
Okay.
I don't know why this is weird.
What is the best job you ever had?
That ain't weird.
This one.
Besides this job, what's the best job?
It doesn't say that.
No, it says what is the
best job you've ever had?
This one.
This is the best job I've ever had.
This is definitely the
best job I've ever had.
Second best job I've ever
had is not an obvious choice.
It turns out I really haven't liked jobs.
I mean, for me, this feels
like a pretty easy answer.
It has to be our time on staff.
Yeah.
With Campus Crusade.
Yeah, I guess that's right.
I mean,
'cause we were basically doing kind of
what we're doing now.
Yeah, I agree with that.
Just with the Jesus twist.
Yeah, give me another.
That one's just not that weird.
Yeah, I know.
It's weird that it
would ask that question.
So strange that it wasn't weird.
What?
Have you ever been in a
car accident or seen one?
No, I've never seen one.
I've never seen one.
No. This is interesting.
'Cause you were in a pretty,
were you with your mom
in that car accident?
No. My mom broke her back.
I was not in the van.
Yeah, okay.
You weren't there.
So what's the most, what's
the craziest accident
you've ever been in?
Is it the one that I was there for?
You're talking about the,
the Halloween egging?
That's the craziest car
accident I've ever been in.
My head broke the windshield.
Yeah.
That was my, that was my doing.
Yeah. Yeah.
I think, I mean, that was scary.
That was, that was kind of traumatic.
It was very shocking.
I mean, we're egging
houses with our friends.
We don't recommend that.
It's me and you,
and in my 1987 Nissan
pickup that I still own.
It's at my mom's house.
Yeah.
And Heather sitting in the
middle of the bench seat.
And then how many people
are we saying now?
I'm still gonna say eight.
Eight people in the back.
Eight people in the back,
three people in the
front, total of eleven.
We're, you know, you egg people's houses,
and then you flee the scene,
and it's, it had been
raining a little bit,
and we're leaving this
neighborhood that I never go in,
you know?
What was it called?
It was really nice.
Really nice.
And Andrew.
And then, so I didn't see the stop sign
'til it was too late.
And then it was, the road
didn't continue straight.
You had to turn right
or left when you stopped
at the stop sign, which
I was going through,
at I don't know, 35 miles an hour.
Try again.
So I, 45?
Mmm yeah. 50.
So I slammed on brakes until I realized
that like, oh, there's
just a field out there.
So then I was just like, we're
just gonna go into the field.
But there was like a
huge ditch that wha-bam.
We like go down into this
ditch and then we hit.
So we had so much momentum
that like we hit the ditch
and then popped up on the other side
and like came to rest in the field.
And when I looked around, the front,
my front windshield was cracked.
Thanks to your forehead.
Well, in my perspective,
I get into the car after
having thrown eggs.
And of course, when you're
in an egging situation,
and you're getting in and out of your car,
you don't put your seatbelt on.
Also, it was like 1995 in North Carolina.
I mean, you didn't wear your
seatbelt that much anyway.
We were dumb.
And so.
No one in the back was wearing seatbelts.
Yeah, all the people in the back.
So I just was basically just a free fall.
Not free fall, but just a free throw.
Like my head, boom.
Right there on the part of your head
that you would headbutt someone
with, hits the windshield,
completely shatters the windshield.
I come back to the seat.
I think Heather's head hit the middle part
and knocked the mirror off.
Yeah.
She comes back, and then the
car sort of comes to a stop.
And the first thing I did was
laugh because I was in shock
to some extent, but I was in shock
that this had just
happened and I wasn't hurt.
But then we heard the crying and wailing,
and I looked over to my right and left.
And like the people, the friends of mine
who were in the back of the
truck are now all in the field.
We thought we had killed people.
I thought I had tossed everybody out.
But they had just jumped out in terror.
But my ex-girlfriend at the time.
She was like, I'm bleeding, I'm bleeding.
I'm bleeding all over my face.
And we're like, we're like, it's egg.
You have egg all over you.
Right. Yeah.
You're not bleeding.
Of course, one guy was bleeding
because he had the worst injury.
Shout out to Don.
He, oh, okay.
Yeah, Don and Brooks,
they both were seated
against the back of the cab.
Oh, Brooks too.
So they hit the, they hit
the back of my back windows
of my truck and broke
those, and broke their face.
But I think.
They both have permanent face scars.
Did Brooks have a permanent face scar?
I believe so.
I knew that Don had one.
Yeah, Don definitely has
a face scar from that.
That's, that's my worst story.
Look, you got that one outta me again.
Yeah, and I was there, so.
And it was so weird.
Here's another weird one.
I think maybe,
That was weird.
I think that maybe this would be weird.
We're just so weird.
If you were on a date.
'Cause it would be weird to ask
what's the size of your shoes?
What?
Yeah, that is really weird.
On like a first date,
there's like a lull in the conversation,
and you're like, what's
the size of your shoes?
Like, just pick one, left or right.
What's the size?
Well, mine are a little bit different.
My left one's a little bit bigger.
Mine too.
But it's not worth getting
a half size different.
Mm-mm.
Rhett, thank you for asking
such a weird question.
I wear a size 11.
And for the longest time,
you also wore an 11.
We had the same size shoe.
You wear a, you went
up to a 12, didn't you?
You wear a 12?
I have always been a 12,
I've been a 12 for many, many years.
I've been a 12 since high school.
And I have 13s in Pumas.
Okay.
Consistently Puma's a
little bit tight on the 12.
So I go 13 on Pumas.
Hmm.
I wear a, yeah, a 10 and a
half to an 11 and a half.
It depends on the brand.
Okay.
Well that was, I'm sorry it
got a little weird there.
Okay.
Talking about like, our shoe sizes.
I switched to creative mode.
This is a creative question.
Come on, let's try this.
Do you believe in Bigfoot?
Absolutely not.
No, no, no.
Do you?
No.
I mean, I just, I'm
just checking and seeing
if you've changed your view.
I'm cool with it.
I'm cool with Bigfoot, and I
could be wrong, but like, no.
I mean, they're discovering
species all the time,
but they're like deep in a jungle
that is not a Sasquatchian jungle.
And they're like small things,
like an Amazonian rodent frog.
Like a frog.
Or, you know, there's more
bugs that we don't know
than we do.
So I'm kind of making an argument
for like a small Sasquatch in the Amazon,
but that ain't Sasquatch.
Here's, I definitely do
not believe in Bigfoot.
Right?
There's just absolutely no good reason
to believe in Bigfoot.
However, at this point,
I don't think I could be
presented with evidence
that would make me believe in Bigfoot.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Right.
It's so unbelievable at this point
that if somebody was like,
we have definitive proof of Bigfoot,
Too late.
I just, I don't think,
I don't think you could do
anything to change my mind.
Which I'm just saying that
that's how made up my mind is
about this particular thing.
Yeah. Crying Wolf.
Too many people have cried Bigfoot.
There's been too many TV shows about it
where they haven't produced a Bigfoot.
Yeah.
You think a TV show searching for Bigfoot,
if they could find a
Bigfoot, they would have,
you know?
You think they'd hold back on that?
Maybe to get a couple
more seasons out of it.
But eventually you gotta show
a little bit of the Bigfoot.
You got, you got to.
I haven't even invested.
But let's talk about Yeti though.
'Cause I had the classic
conversation with a fellow.
You believe this is different?
Oh, this is very different.
So like, I dropped, I was picking up Lando
from his flag football
practice, and they're like,
I got to know the other parents.
we're like, you know,
we're hitting it off.
I'm telling you.
I found a new friend group Rhett.
I'm just telling you.
It's my son's parents.
They're a good group of people.
Your son's parents?
That would be you.
Oh yeah, that's me.
My son's friends' parents.
Oh okay. Yeah.
I left the friend out.
That makes more sense.
Yeah, I do like hanging out with myself.
Or you could be talking about your wife.
You know, and there
was a guy sitting there
in a chair, in a folding chair,
and he was like, and
there was an open one.
So I sat in his other chair.
I don't know why he brought two.
It was only him, but I guess to share.
And I was like, damn, this
is a, this is a nice chair.
I looked back at it,
and it said Yeti on it.
This is one of them Yeti chairs.
Oh, okay.
And then he's like,
well yeah, I, you know,
I travel to so many different things,
and I have to sit down.
I wanted to splurge and
give myself a nice chair.
I was like, well, you know,
Yeti's where it's at.
And before you know it, we're
having that dad conversation
about everything that you should get
from, not a sponsor, Yeti.
Okay.
You know.
I know about the coolers.
Oh, they've got the cooler
that goes on your back,
and oh, it's, you put ice in that thing,
three days later it's still ice.
You know, this is, these
are the conversations
that you get in when you're in full dad
at a flag football game mode.
So you're just saying you
believe in Yeti as a brand?
I believe in Yeti as a brand.
I think you can count on Yeti,
but you're gonna have to fork
some dough to get that Yeti.
You know what I'm saying?
Do you own any Yeti products?
I own a Yeti cooler.
You do?
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
That I got for my solo trip.
That's a big deal.
And I don't think
I've used it since then
because I just don't
have many cooler needs.
People, you know, it's,
we're in an age where like
products come out of the woodwork
that are like super specialized,
and then they're advertised on Instagram,
and it's basically like,
Speaking of.
hey, you're gonna pay
out the nose for this,
but we've done all this
work to figure it out.
Like, I'm getting a lot of Instagram ads
for all types of bags.
Well, have you seen Hover Glide?
No.
The bag that I've seen
is one that is like,
it looks, it's got four
zippers across a duffle bag.
I don't know what it's called.
Again, not a sponsor.
And it's like, so each
compartment you can,
you can organize things in different ways,
and it's like very, it's very enthralling.
Look at this.
I think you're gonna want this.
And then there's another bag I saw
where it starts off and you're like,
you put a suit in it, and
then you roll it over,
and turn it into a duffle bag.
I've seen that.
Look at this.
And what's this guy doing?
Floating backpack?
It's the HoverGlide.
This is invented by a professor,
like a biology professor from somewhere.
So the backpack's on your
back, and as you move,
like as you walk or jump or anything,
the backpack is like on
some sort of spring system.
So I actually, so I already
watched this whole video.
Patented technology.
It's on a track that, this
is the guy that invented it,
and it has these bands,
these elastic bands.
It looks like the backpack
is staying completely motionless
as you're moving up and down.
Dr. Lawrence Rome,
a biology professor at the
University of Pennsylvania.
He's been working on this
project for the past 15 years.
Yeah, you know what it is though?
Of course, this came out in 2018.
It's a steady cam dude.
Haven't you ever seen
a steady cam operator?
Yeah, but why?
How come this hasn't caught on?
It's like,
It's steady cam technology.
This video came out in 2018.
It's 2022.
Did the pandemic ruin all momentum
that this floating backpack had?
Because that could be
me and you right there
running across the city square,
and our backpack's just
staying completely motionless
as we go up and down.
That could be me and you, man.
We could be doing jumping
jacks on the steps.
Well, why does he keep
doing jumping jacks?
Because it's a great way to
illustrate how this works.
Yeah, but I don't do jumping
jacks with a backpack on.
Well they say it like reduces
the load like about 80%.
You know, I don't know if it's true,
but I'm just saying if you're into bags,
I would think that you
might have this one.
If you started rolling with this backpack,
this backpack that makes it look like.
I'm not into bags.
What?
You just said you were
getting advertised bags.
Okay, so you're sending the
wrong messages to Instagram.
I look at 'em, you're right.
I guess proof's in the pudding.
I freaking look at these ads.
Listen.
But I never buy the bags.
The robots are smarter than you.
Robots know you better
than you know yourself.
That's true.
The robots know you want a bag,
and you might want this bag.
I don't know.
I don't know you man.
Hey Rhett and Link.
Y'all got time to talk to me?
Oh yeah.
We always got time to talk to you.
Hey Dad.
Thanks for joining us.
Hey.
Yeah, I don't know about these tool boxes,
but you know, you probably could,
I don't know whether
you need to get one made
out of a cooler or not.
You can just go to Lowe's
and get a good toolbox.
That's what I,
see, that's what I was
talking about a toolbox.
He was listening to you.
He was listening.
Is that why you called?
What, I was told that you
wanted to call in but.
No, I didn't wanna call in to get
in between y'all's toolboxes.
I called in to try to help people to know
about Dispatches from Myrtle Beach.
That's why I called.
Oh, yep. Okay.
Okay.
I like this plan.
I got a ulterior motive.
I'm telling you.
So you wanna pull
everybody from this podcast
into your podcast?
And you know what?
Hey, that's fine by me.
I'm just kind of conveniently
involved in both of 'em.
Yeah, and I'm in full
support of you listening
to both Ear Biscuits and
Dispatches from Myrtle Beach.
Well that, that's what we
wanna try to get people to do.
Hope they keep, I know they gonna
keep watching Ear Biscuits.
We trying to get that many people
to watch Dispatches from Myrtle Beach.
'Cause we having a good
time and swinging stuff
around the world.
And we might even might even teach you
how to dance or something.
Oh yeah.
I've learned quite a bit listening.
There's a lot to learn.
Yeah, but I do know looking at the data
that there's roughly, like, four times
as many people listening to Ear Biscuits
as to Dispatches from Myrtle Beach.
Dad, how do you feel about that?
Well, y'all been doing that a lot longer
than we've been doing Dispatches, so.
Okay. That's true.
Maybe in about six months.
Just give us about six
months, and we going to see
if we can't catch y'all,
get pretty close anyway.
Okay.
So right now.
We're gonna work hard at this.
So right now, if somebody
listens to Ear Biscuits,
there is, you know, if four people listen,
one person says, I'm also gonna listen
to Dispatches from Myrtle Beach.
But in six months, you're
saying all four of 'em
are gonna listen.
All five of them.
Oh, more people.
Yeah.
I don't, you know, it's, yeah,
it is good for everybody,
if you can tolerate a dirty joke or two.
Just once in a while.
Yeah, we have some people
ask some funky questions.
And I mean we've been taking a break,
so it was like four weeks off for us.
Have you missed making the show?
Oh yeah. I like doing it.
It's fun.
But I don't know if I'm gonna
let us take a break again
like this or not.
Uh oh.
I told you Rhett.
I told you.
Rhett asked me, it's like, are you,
are you making your dad do this?
I'm like, hey, he likes it.
He likes it.
Well, you seem to to be enjoying yourself.
Oh, I enjoy, it's fun.
It's kind of like, well people,
some people know about SOS
is Society of Shaggers.
It's a shagging thing that
we have for about 10 days
down here in the fall.
And my shirts came in that said,
do you know who I am?
Yes.
And that's what I ask
people a lot of times,
and it's really got to do
with you and Link, Rhett.
I said, do y'all, you know
who Rhett and Link are?
But this lady older
than me walked up to me
and read my shirt, and she
says, I don't know who you are.
I said, and Nancy was with
me, and Nancy said what?
He's got a famous son, and
a man that works with him
that's famous, and they do
stuff on YouTube and stuff.
You're the man that works.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Well y'all work together, whatever.
No, I understood.
I'll take that.
But she, she didn't know who good,
she didn't know what Good
Mythical Morning was.
But I did tell her about
Dispatches from Myrtle Beach.
Look that up
Yes.
on a podcast.
So, you know, that's just my
job when I'm talking to people.
Yeah.
That's guerilla marketing.
Guerilla marketing.
And dad, I mean, if dad
takes his shirt off,
it would definitely be
like gorilla marketing,
'cause he is hairy.
Hey, that's like the people
I talked to on the beach
that day and asked about you two.
And all I had on was my swimming trunk
and a cold beer in my hand, by the way.
But anyway.
Dad, would you be willing
to take your shirt off
and have Dispatches
from Myrtle Beach shaved
into your body hair?
No.
Yeah, you gotta draw the line somewhere.
I'm drawing no, no.
What about your email address?
Not that either.
Ratherbshaggin53@aol.com.
That would be tough
That's a lot of letters.
It's harder to read.
Yeah. Yeah.
You got any, got any emails
you wanna share with us?
We just had, we'll, yeah, I got one.
But if we gonna do a sign,
we'll just get another t-shirt made up
with all that stuff on it.
We ain't doing that to my chest.
Yeah, just get a t-shirt made
before you get something
shaved into your chest hair.
Yeah. Just.
But I have got a question that
Randy Johnson sent in to us.
The pitcher?
Well now, you know, it don't say that.
But that, I know who, I
remember that Randy Johnson,
that was about six foot,
about as tall as you probably.
I think he was taller than me. Yeah.
Yeah. He was about 6'10" or
6'11" and could throw heat.
He could throw heat.
I guess he's a fan of the show.
Yeah, might be.
If you guys make too much of
a connection over baseball,
then you're gonna have to have
your own baseball podcast.
Okay.
And Rhett, you going with
all the hair you got,
you gonna like this.
Okay.
It says, what do you call
a smiling Roman soldier
with a piece of hair
stuck between his teeth.
A smiling Roman soldier
with a piece of hair stuck
between his teeth.
I know it. I figured it out.
I know it.
Okay.
Has it got the word centurion in it?
Well, you can try.
Try. Just give it a shot.
What do you call a Roman soldier
smiling with hair in between his teeth?
He's a hair or something.
Made a movie about it.
Okay.
Yep. Okay.
So it's got something
to do with Gladiator.
Oh, Gladiator.
That's it. There you go.
There you go.
Yeah.
And that was it.
So sometimes I give a good
hint Rhett, once in a while.
But why did you say with
someone as much hair
as Rhett, he would like it?
'Cause hey, because you know,
if he was like that Roman soldier,
he wouldn't know if it
was his hair or hers
that was between his teeth.
Okay.
Well, a lot of Dispatches
from Myrtle Beach
is the struggle and discovery
of punch lines.
I enjoy this.
You want me to join?
No.
We gotta keep the fun between us.
This is a father son thing.
Yeah, it's a bonding thing.
I don't need to be there,
just every once in a while.
You know, like right now.
Yeah, you can join us, you know,
every once a quarter or something, Rhett.
Until we get enough of
the audience to move over,
I think we're just gonna
have to keep getting you
to join this podcast.
Wow Dad.
So, I mean, I don't want you
to share any more of the jokes.
You gotta keep your best
stuff for Dispatches.
Oh, I got some stuff.
I got some stuff for
starting this coming week.
Boy, I mean, I've been recognized
at about six or seven places.
He always, you know,
he always tells the story
of getting recognized.
Yeah.
Well, no, I didn't tell the
story in half of these places.
They just recognize me.
Oh yeah.
It's happening.
All right, well save it, save
it for our recording session.
Again, Dispatches from Myrtle Beach
comes out this coming Thursday.
And yeah, then we're back every Thursday.
But Dad, can you talk directly
to Ear Biscuits listeners.
Again, three outta four have
not given it a chance yet.
So just can you speak directly to them?
Give 'em your wholehearted pitch.
Well all you Ear Biscuits fans,
I would really like for y'all
to start watching Dispatches
from Myrtle Beach because.
Well, don't say watch,
'cause it's only audio.
I mean listen to everything
on Dispatches from Myrtle Beach
because you might learn some words
that you ain't never heard
before if you just come
and just wanna, just listen to me talk,
and just see what you learn about it.
So, and listen, we have a good time,
and I got an email address,
ratherbshaggin53@aol.com,
and you people on Ear
Biscuits can send us,
send me some questions, and
I'll do my best to answer 'em,
and see what we can do with that.
So just come on and swing.
I always like to tell
people we swinging around
in this show, like while I'm
swinging when I'm dancing.
So just come on and have a
good time from Ear Biscuits
to Dispatches From Myrtle Beach.
Ratherbshaggin, the letter
B, no G on shagging,
the numbers 5 3 @aol.com.
And it's not much of a
time commitment, right?
I mean, you guys keep it under,
you keep it under 40 minutes, right?
Oh, it's 30 minutes every episode.
30 minutes.
Yeah, you can add it to your life.
It will make you happy.
I tell you, Dad, you make
me happy every single week.
Well it's good.
I've missed it.
It was good to see both of y'all.
I'm telling you.
I get to see you, you
know, with what we do,
and I reckon it'd be hard
for me to say you knOw,
I'll be glad to be seeing
y'all down in Austin, Texas,
and then.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
We're looking forward to that.
We're gonna have a good time at MythiCon.
I'm telling you.
So we've done a little
stuff with that too.
So looking forward to that.
And us, you know, getting
to bond a little bit
and have a good time.
Yep.
And get more listeners.
All right, Dad, that was
a very effective plug.
If that doesn't do it,
I don't know what will.
Well.
No notes.
I try to do the best I can do
to do what we enjoy doing.
So if I need to, I'm
gonna let y'all get back
to Ear Biscuits and talk
about toolboxes or something.
Yeah, yeah.
We'll pick up where we left off.
All right, Dad,
I'll see you soon for our next recording.
Okay. All right.
Love both of y'all.
Love you too.
Bye.
Isn't he the greatest?
He is.
He's just so.
He's a natural.
He's so, he's just fallen
right into it, you know?
He's completely embraced it.
Yeah.
He's found a new calling.
He hasn't quit his day job yet, you know.
Well, maybe
He's still painting.
If he could get enough listeners.
Still painting.
You can do that.
We'll get there.
I do have a question for you.
Is it weird?
This one's, it's under the weird category,
but to me it's more
interesting than weird.
If you were offered the
position of mayor of your city,
would you take it?
This reads.
Mayor of Los Angeles or Burbank?
Mayor of Burbank?
Sure.
Being a politician in any,
that just seems like a nightmare to me.
You know, it's like, I respect
people who are, who can,
who do it, and especially
if they keep their
integrity intact, you know?
But like being in a
position where you've got
to please the people, you
know, it's like we have fans
that we have to, we, you
know, if they're not happy,
this arrangement isn't working.
But at the same time,
it's not 100% of our job
to make people happy.
You know?
It is a big part of it,
but you know what I'm saying?
Like, something about it's a,
like being a politician is like a,
if you're doing it right, it's
a complete act of service.
And that's just, I mean, I
guess I'm too selfish for that.
I think very, I mean, maybe
I'm being too cynical,
but I don't think,
we don't have to have these
headphones on anymore.
Oh, let's take these off.
Look at us.
I don't think.
Are we good to just keep going?
Okay.
I don't think most
people get into politics
for selfless reasons.
Right?
Mm-hmm.
Even, I mean, you can.
As a service.
There can even be a
selfishness in being selfless.
You know?
It's like, if you find
joy in being selfless,
isn't that selfish?
Like Mother Teresa, you know,
wanted to get up and help
people because every morning,
because she found fulfillment in that.
Yeah, if you wanna get to the root of it,
I would say that yeah, if you follow,
if you actually are following your,
you're making decisions
for your own benefit
and for your own wellbeing,
most often you will do good
things to other people.
Right?
Like most people will end
up, oh, I'm doing good
because it makes me feel good.
And I don't think there's
anything wrong with that.
No.
But I guess what I'm saying is,
this is an interesting question because
I've heard somebody say
relatively recently actually,
that, you know, we spend
a lot of time thinking
about national elections,
and we, you know,
everybody, like, if you're
gonna vote, you vote
for the presidential election.
Right.
And you'll vote for some other things.
But actually, to affect
cha, now, first of all,
we believe in that.
Vote for the national elections.
Go to votelikeabeast.com,
get registered to vote, whatever.
That is, we believe in that.
But really, you have a lot
more power in your vote
at a local level, right?
Right.
And I'm a bit cynical when it comes
to politicians in general.
And I think many of us are.
Right?
Because you think about
it, you got, you know,
sort of the, you've got the Senate, right?
Just a hundred people.
And that's a pretty impressive position
to make it in politics.
Like if you make it to the Senate,
like that's a big deal.
Yeah.
House of Representatives,
little bit easier.
Right.
And I think it's reflected in the nature.
The vibe.
There's some people in the House
that are just absolute nuts.
I mean, there's people in
the Senate who are nuts too,
but there's some people in
the House that are just like,
how does this person become
a national politician, a representative?
And then you go even lower than that,
and you get into like state legislators.
Yeah.
It can get pretty freewheeling.
The people who make a
series of life decisions,
where they find themselves in a position
to run for local office, you know,
this isn't necessarily the
best and the brightest.
I mean, I'm not, I'm just saying.
I'm just saying that.
But those elections, that those people
are actually really, really important.
So when it comes to
the mayor of your town,
I guess it's one thing to
say like Mayor of Los Angeles
or Burbank, but like just a
mayor of your average town,
Like that's a really important,
I think it's a really important position.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I'm a little too intimidated
to sign up for that,
even in a small town.
Seems like, I don't know.
I couldn't see you doing it either.
Well I mean, I jokingly talk
about political campaigns all the time,
because I'm, I have just
enough blind confidence
to get to a place where I
feel like I've got something
to say and could motivate somebody.
And maybe I could believe
in something enough
where I felt like, you
know, political will
was the most important part of it.
But I'm never gonna
allow myself to do that.
Do you have a recommendation?
I do.
I think by the time you hear this,
you will have seen Justin Long as a guest
on Good Mythical Morning.
Yes.
And he was there to promote
his movie Barbarian.
It's a scary movie.
A horror movie that I saw last night.
Yeah, let me tell you.
It was so good.
Oh, it's so scary, and it's
funny, and it's creative
the way that it was done.
It was just kind of innovative
and kind of keeps you
on the edge of your seat.
And Justin Long is great in it.
He's just, he's really funny.
He just plays a complete a-hole.
But he plays such a good a-hole,
and I just highly recommend it
if you're into horror movies.
When he came on the show,
when he first met us, he
looked at you, and he said
you look like one of the
henchmen from Superman 2.
And he.
And what was the guy's name?
Well, he went on to say,
you know who you look like?
It was Zod's henchman.
He's like, it's almost uncanny.
It's almost uncanny.
And then we pulled up, it was not Zod,
it was this guy, Non.
Non. Non just grunted.
Non from Superman movie.
And it was not a compliment.
Justin Long called you Non.
But, and I will say
there is a resemblance.
Henchman to Zod.
Yeah. The real guy's
name is Jack O'Hallaran.
Halloran.
That sounds like witness protection.
Oh, he had a lot of movies.
Yeah, he's quite a character actor.
Look at him.
I do have a passing resemblance,
like he could be my brother,
but because he went on
to say you look like him,
but I mean you're more,
you're more handsome.
'Cause once we like brought
up a picture of him,
you're like a handsome version of him.
Handsome version of Non.
I didn't hold it against him.
He's returning the favor.
But see the Barbarian.
He was great in that movie.
We'll speak at you next week.
Remember to call us,
give us your responses,
and we'll play him at the end.
1-88, Earpod1.
Earpod1.
Hashtag Ear Biscuits.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
Probably already a
little late to this one,
but I just wanted let you
guys know that I was 25
when I learned that zippers lock.
I didn't know this.
If you put them all the way down,
they lock, and you can't
pull open your pants.
Have a mythical day.
Hey Rhett and Link,
I just wanted to say that I
listen to almost every podcast,
and it's crazy to see how
the podcasts have grown.
But I recently, oh, not so
recently, went to therapy
because both of you proved to me
that nothing has to be wrong with you
to go to therapy.
And little did I realize
that throughout therapy,
the anxiety and stress were going away.
And listening to your podcast
and growing with you felt amazing.
And I'm so proud to say
that my therapist even says
that I graduated from therapy.
Now it felt like I was kind
of going through a breakup
with my therapist, but it was amazing.
And I just have to thank you two
for being there along the side with me.
And I guess you're my new thing.
You're my new therapy.
Woo-wee! Let me tell you something Rhett.
You wrote a hell of a blues tune there.
Kill a man.
I'm telling you what.
My name's Hunter.
I'm out in Michigan.
I just gotta tell you what, man.
I'm proud of you.
This album is fricking awesome.
Okay, so keep doing it.
Put out another one.
Get Link on that, Matt.
Love you guys.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.